la musique adoucit également les moeurs
politiques le nouveau ministre de la
culture et de la francophonie jacques
toubon pratique de ce point de vue la
continuité il célèbre lui aussi la fête
de la musique créées par jack lang en 80
et exporter aujourd'hui dans 78 pays
elle est destinée à saluer l'arrivée de
l'été jacques toubon a choisi d'être ce
soir à la butte-aux-cailles dans le
xiiie arrondissement de paris
ça n'est pas tout à fait un hasard non
c'est pas mais ça va aller à la
butte-aux-cailles on faisait de la
musique bien avant qu'on fasse la fête
de la musique
donc je crois que c'est un juste retour
des choses d'être pour cette douzième
fête de la musique à la
butte-aux-cailles mon l'ambiance qui
règne autour de nous montre bien que
nous sommes en direct dans le xiiie
arrondissement de paris alors quelle
musique allons nous entendre ce soir à
paris mais aussi dans toutes les villes
de france jacques toubon moi je vais
entendre toutes les musiques en réalité
ici on a la musique populaire
ensuite je vais aller au podium place de
la république
je vais à l'écouté du rock en banlieue
et puis j'irai écouter leurs caisses de
paris au palais royal et les choeurs de
l'armée française aux invalides noyée
que c'est éclectique et c'est en fait
toute la musique alors toute la musique
que toutes les musiques on voit bien
dans les musiques que vous décrivez une
dimension universelle
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un jacques toubon
comme une contradiction entre cette
dimension universelle de la musique et
le repliement de la plupart des nations
y compris la france sur elle-même non je
crois que la musique est un langage
universel et je pense que elle peut
justement parfaitement contribuer
elle peut parfaitement contribué à
réaliser entre les nations cette
compréhension qui est nécessaire c'est
aussi une des dimensions de la fête de
la musique
alors je vais manier le paradoxe ou
jacques toubon ou par glas de la
dimension universelle de la musique
mais parlons à l'instant de la de la
chanson française là je m'adresse au
ministre de la francophonie est ce qu'à
votre avis la chanson française qui se
porte bien en france est menacée dans le
moment je crois que la chanson française
peut se porter très bien la preuve
regardez ce que johnny hallyday a fait
johnny hallyday c'est un chanteur
français y en a bien d'autres
et je suis persuadé que nous pouvons
exporter notre chanson et c'est un des
buts de notre politique c'est d'essayer
de faire en sorte effectivement qu' il
n'y ait pas que la chanson anglo-saxonne
dans le monde mais aussi il faut bien
comprendre que la musique c'est un
échange et la musique anglo saxonne
elle est aussi notre musique à nous
merci jacques toubon va se rendre